you
I'm gonna let you intro everyone hit us
good morning millennial good morning
Jeremy when they want to join the group
and they have to say their favorite
episode in my and I get so many any time
that you're on it's you it's funny we
were just at a meet-and-greet for
Claudia at so stuff which I don't know
where you were I guess missing in action
I'm benefiting the HRC and one of the
core ideas home setting up the podcasts
that we recorded for yesterday's episode
so that we would never miss an and one
of the questions from the audience was
who is Claudia's favorite person to
co-host with and your favorite person to
co-host with and nobody said me who's my
favorite person to co-host
did she say second that nobody said my
name like I tuned that I'm just like
these [ __ ] [ __ ] it was her
favorite person to co-host with um
actually she said that she has never
co-hosted with anybody else or like
she's like done it so few times like
like it's always you and that she's
jealous that like you get to meet so
many cool people and co-host with them
and she's always like she loves
co-hosting with you but like she's
jealous of like the time you'd get with
other people as well I understand sister
well don't be because I'm struggling to
find a co-host for tomorrow and worst
case scenario you will be joining me
again see worst case and also bet no
that's a good worst-case scenario that's
like a great fall back it's just I know
that you're a busy man and I don't want
to have to tap on like I know I'm gonna
need you again Claudia has a long tour
coming up for the rest of her life like
I know that there's only so many times I
can ask you I have some other great
co-host set up for next week
Heather McMann will be joining us I got
out of jury duty so I'll be here for
Kevin and Astrid then on Thursday I'm
not lucky because now I'm going in March
it was postponed to and like I don't
know who knows where I'm gonna be in
March I'll probably have a new excuse
like I dodged your every vintage or II
didn't maybe Colton will be on in March
and then I'll be like I can't sorry like
Colton's coming on my show that he's
algeri did my story with Jerry duty I
get summoned all the time I actually it
feels like all the time I'm sure it
feels like that what for everyone back
in college I did serve jury duty but I
only went for one day and it was just it
was not for me
so I didn't go back the second day and I
guess
technically that doesn't count as
surveillance stinks yeah I just I really
couldn't go back again it wasn't like
the time for me to do jury duty was like
I was on summer vacation from college
like I just want to sleep in I'm not
going down to Pearl Street at 8:00 a.m.
but like now I'm an adult I can go down
to Pearl Street at 8:00 a.m. they had no
business calling on me back in the day
but I'm ready to serve jury duty I
actually think I think I would enjoy it
like I'm gonna serve like juror Hawaii
it's gonna be a moment what if I get
picked yeah I dodged it for eight years
I got summons like summons or summoned
summoned you get your Jersey your jury
summons summoned will send you okay I
was summoned eight times and finally
they sent me a note and I never went and
they finally sent me you know like if
you don't come you're going to prison so
I went and I was out in three hours Wow
just because I'm lucky I mean must be
nice also the problem with jury duty is
downtown they're like there really are
no good lunch options maybe I'll bring
my own maybe I'll bring a sandwich or
something none none and are you allowed
to bring a computer and watch TV while
you wait you are allowed to bring a
computer look you're not let's take
pictures that's what they say so well
who would even want to the lighting down
there is horrendous but I really do look
forward to serving my country you know
my country has served me and now it's
time to give back it's not even serving
your country I don't even know what they
do they're like what do they really do
well just like have you sit in a room
you look up on the left anybody's been
to jury duty knows this there's a small
monitor where they tell you to shut off
your beeper and like they need to like
fix that from 1970 like they don't even
mention cellphones it's like turn off
your beepers like are you crazy
like the amount of money the government
has they can't update that video and
then you sit there they call your name
they ask you like are you going on a
trip in the next two weeks
everybody says that they're going on a
pre-planned trip and then everybody gets
out I don't know who actually serves
well people do serve and now that I've
also seen American crime story Oh Jay
Simpson I know how important jury
selection is and I also do watch
billions no I think you would really
like it I just caught up and Jerry
suction you know
important there too so I just you know
I'm gonna get in the game the 2d marker
to Diamond Kirby I understand I was
there I was there once upon a time I it
is the greatest show of all time it's so
great it's unbelievable
I'm glad that you're there and I'm
thinking about it I just watched the
jury duty episode with Larry where he
claims to be a racist oh right and gets
off of jury duty but then ends up
meeting the same guy again
I think Claudia was telling us that she
saw that episode with you when last time
I talking about jury duty it was like it
was in these same tears every time I
think about jury duty I feel weirdly
think of that one episode of 7th heaven
where Beverly Mitchell like doesn't want
to serve and then like the whole episode
is a lesson where she learns like how
important it is for her to like
participate as a citizen and then it's
just like but her dad's a child molester
in real life so then it's all ruined for
me but anyways I think that song yes
that's funny
what's really funny is that like a bunch
of 11 and 12 year old Jewish kids
we're like watching a show about a
pastor and his wife and like it never
really clicked for me they're like I was
just watching like a Christian show it's
like there's nothing wrong but I'm just
saying I'm a young Jewish lad and didn't
put those those two together no and
what's really crazy is that the Reverend
yes is John that's the craziest part I
don't know also I can't think about jury
duty without thinking about the rural
juror world you love him/her but anyways
this Jerry talk is a great segue into
our first story so without further ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast okay we
have two cases of justice being served
yesterday
jurors across the world ruled in our
favor well actually yes jurors across
the world ruled in our favor in the Bill
Cosby case he was sentenced to 3 to 10
years in prison for his discretions on
Tuesday afternoon Bill Cosby was
processed at the Montgomery Correctional
Facility in Eagleville Pennsylvania
after being sentenced to 3 to 10 years
in the state prison he was also fined 25
thousand dollars plus the cost of
prosecution not long after Cosby was
then moved to state correctional
institution at Phoenix a state prison
for diagnostic and intake there his
health his needs and health issues will
be evaluated as officials decide which
prison best suits him overall this
process was which every inmate in the
state prison system goes through could
take anywhere from weeks to months a me
warden of the Pennsylvania Department of
Corrections told CNN last week several
factors go into this overall evaluation
including the prisoners age and sexually
violent predator assessment quote the
Department of Corrections has had a high
profile inmate has had high profile
inmates before and I'm sure we'll have
them again so it's not that much out of
the ordinary but he will be treated like
the other inmates reports CNN mm-hmm so
this is a long time coming yes like 50
years in the making yes three to ten
years it's better than nothing I know
people are some people are upset that
it's not enough time but it's something
it's something and I am glad I have two
feelings the only number one if we're
putting elderly people in prison and all
elderly people needs to go into prison
so that's like something that like
people on social media are talking about
Bill Cosby should go to jail there's no
question and he should be going for way
more than three to ten years he should
be going for life at this point which
the three to ten years in all honesty
could be life because he's an 81 year
old man right he deserves to go to
prison
we just need to figure out if we feel
bad for old people going to prison or if
we don't because there are many cases
where the elderly are not required to go
to prison because they're old and what
the hell are they going to do because
they're so old like Bill Cosby at 81 god
forbid he does drugged and raped someone
but he's 81 so you probably won't know
anything we're putting them in prison so
they don't do it again it's we're
putting them in prison to punish them
for the things that they did totally he
deserves to go to he deserves to go to
prison I just want like a line drawn if
you are an old person you commit a crime
that was like 50 years ago and it
happens like either you go to jail
everyone or you don't go to jail well it
wouldn't be 50 years ago because then
the statute of limitations runs out he's
only going to jail for this little
because it's only one case that was
tried against him because the rest were
like so long ago that they can't
prosecute he's an [ __ ] I'm not saying
he's not and he deserves to go to jail
but you're saying all elderly people
should
jail for the crimes they commit or not
like yes just like like it's it's sad
when you're an old an old person for
their family whatever it is he deserves
to go to prison I'm just saying that
either send all of the elderly to prison
that committed crimes or allow them or
have like some elderly prison where like
they can like sit in their rocking
chairs and go off into the sunset
yeah away from humanity but not in jail
okay I think that's fair elderly prison
let's get on it you guys yeah that's my
take um I understand I just feel I do
feel like every case is everything I
also feel like I don't know like you're
talking about I think one specific
elderly piece where someone didn't go to
prison yes and they actually have lived
for ten years since then yes um I don't
know enough so like I'm not you know
these like tests yes it seems like when
they bring them in to see if they're fit
for prison so he's definitely not gonna
be held as fit for prison you think so
yeah I don't know he's blind
- yes you see or he's he's saying he's
blind he's been saying he's blind what
is wrong with like TV and movies and
like what is wrong with this whole
entertainment industry
yeah that that's that's the word that I
was going for like what is wrong with
Hollywood that all of these people that
seem like such wholesome characters I
think what about the guy from Blue's
Clues remember him oh yeah what did he
do he was a child molester no and like
it's all of these like child TV shows
like I don't understand is it the
network that's just like hiring bad
people or does the industry attorney in
the industry I think it hires bad people
and turns you and when we were talking
about this in our last anti episode he
was saying like you got to a level of
power you can have anything that you
want and like so then it goes you know
you know you're just having like sex
with people consensually but then that
gets boring and then you take it to the
next level the next level and the next
level and because this like the power
that you have you just can't stop
wielding over people and that's how you
become I mean I don't understand sickos
Saeko I mean the whole industry is crap
we try and talk about it all the time
but it's really [ __ ] depressing
honestly it is but I feel like the Bill
Cosby I was reading with like he was one
of the biggest cases in the beginning of
the me to movement and just seeing him
put away is a win yes it's a win yes
speaking of people
going away southern charm star thomas
ravenel was charged in a sexual assault
case reality star thomas ravenel was
arrested thursday after a former nanny
said he fondled her at his south
carolina home featured in his TV show
southern charm nearly 40 years ago
Ravenel 56 was charged with misdemeanor
second-degree assault and battery
according to a sworn statement from
Charleston Creech police which said they
had photos of the injuries caused when
the women woman's underwire bra cut into
her chest and her shirt got caught
around her neck as Ravenel tried to
forcibly take off her clothes
Bravo releases steam and shortly after
saying Ravenel will no longer appear on
the network's southern charm show
Ravenel is already offend a felon he was
arrested in 2007 less than a year into
his term as South Carolina treasurer
after he bought cocaine for himself and
his friends the real estate developer
pleaded guilty and spent ten months in
prison and in 2014 he pleaded guilty to
driving under the influence on Long
Island which resulted in his license
being suspended for six months Wow well
third time's a charm he third time's a
southern charm yes he was finally
arrested for one of the many atrocities
that he has committed he was let out on
bail yesterday but I believe that this
is the beginning of the end for Thomas
Ravenel and this is the beginning of a
very happy beginning for Kathryn who
will probably get full custody of her
children after losing custody completely
you don't watch southern charm do you I
watch it I've watched enough that I I
don't want currently I have watch yes so
you know who Thomas says yes between yes
yes this has been just a long time
coming I'm so and Kathryn was posting to
her Instagram story yesterday and I feel
like she's just trying to tell us that
you know she's in a good place she was
just like working out with Danny
launching her new home mine and it's
like if she were affected by this in a
negative way she wouldn't post at all
but you know she's trying to tell us
life is going on in life is good for her
and I'm really happy about it also I
wonder where this leaves Ashley Jacobs
who was dating Thomas mmm she's
technically Chyna from this show but
once there's an arrest you can undo a
China for the time being yeah um I
wonder like if she'll see him by her man
probably not because he's no longer on
southern charm and she just wants to be
on TV mm-hmm I don't have intend to say
about this he's a sicko I don't know
what's wrong with everyone yeah the only
thing that I want to say is to every
single woman watching this like men in
general or not like this and I don't
know why men
Hollywood are such pieces of [ __ ] he's
considered Hollywood to me like I'm not
like why he just like is well he was
doing before he was on the show it seems
like yeah I think this is another case
in abuse of power like he was a powerful
man he's a person like his family has
roots there like since I don't know 1776
and there's a bridge named after like
his family the Ravenel Bridge they cross
it all the time on the show so he's
power to power yeah it's it's like can
none of you have power and not abuse it
it's funny they're just so many people
with power that don't abuse it I don't
know what's wrong with these people
all right like use it for good there
have to me though 99 million that we
don't see except for the two news
stories that we talk about but these
guys are seems to be a pattern with you
that not all men are terrible but like
not at all it's it's terrible
yeah I'm sure and like can't wield it
over other people then they just like
cheat what the [ __ ] that like when we
read these dear toasters and stuff of
people who cheat it's just like first of
all how do you even have time in the day
and second of all like come on it's
crazy it's crazy it's sad it is by the
way we're matching today for a funeral
yeah no we look professions oh we can
you a neural crashing initially go after
it like fine to find a funeral sure cool
cool thank you my water as well also
people are saying you're looking slim
because I'm wearing all black I actually
have had been having some serious
trouble hopping back on my diet
seriously
really yeah I'll do it for like one day
and then I'll get a sugar craving and
I'll cave I've been having a lot of
cravings like last night I'm embarrassed
of what I did
what'd you do I went to Duane Reade he's
got a pint of ice cream got a pack of
cookies what kind of ice cream like
literally the worst [ __ ] ice cream
ever did you know that Duane Reade only
sells their own brand ice cream
delish well now I go to CBS where I
punch South checkout kiosks yeah my mom
literally has never paid for anything at
CVS it's like the the biggest scheme
like you go in there
$100 scan your coupons $5.00 oh oh you
don't do that no oh my god
CBS is known for everything's free I
mean like I would do that but I can't
spend one more minute at that kiosk than
I need to
and the reason why I actually did punch
the CVS self-checkout machine was
because that was trying to put in his
email number punch the Machine I didn't
realize I thought you had like punch in
my gardening just make me so crazy that
it's it's not sensitive to the human
emotion yes you know like we're not
robots
yes it's stuff yeah stuff but yeah so a
pack of cookies a pint of ice cream
again some on like delish brand but I
did get hostess little mini donuts yeah
so that was good night it was honestly a
bad night you know when you're so
excited you're eating it and then as
you're eating you're like oh my god what
the [ __ ] am i doing yeah what's wrong
with me ain't finish and you're just
like yeah sometimes you hit that point
like I was snacking on carbs last night
because Danielle I cold sent us a gift
facet of like delicious cookies that
I've kept in my apartment and like
they're like just little cookies so I
was making a tea I was having some
cookies and I didn't eat like that many
but it's just like I'm with Atkins or
keto like you can't [ __ ] up at all I
mean it's like it's not even like oh I
went over my calorie limit it's like oh
I [ __ ] up the science like now my body
needs like you have to get back into it
yeah so I'm not feeling great but
speaking of carbs yes
Dunkin Donuts is officially dropping the
doughnuts just call it Duncan starting
in January Dunkin Donuts will drop the
doughnuts from ads packages and signage
at new and remodeled stores as well as
social media accounts the maker the
makeover is part of Dunkin Brands
efforts to re label itself as a beverage
led company that focuses on coffees teas
speedy service and to go fooding food
including but not limited to donuts
Duncan says that beverages especially
coffee make up 60% of the company's Us
sales our new branding is one of the
many things we are doing as a part of
our blueprint for growth to modernize
the Duncan experience for our customer
said Dunkin Brands CEO David Hoffman in
a statement Tuesday okay on the one hand
I do feel like this is again like the
war on carbs
you know and as someone who doesn't eat
car I don't think of it I don't support
the war on carbs because people should
be able to eat what they want like we're
changing a 2ww because watching your
weight like isn't healthy I can't and I
shan't but I don't know if this is
exactly that because it seems like
they're just trying to extend their
umbrella and encompass more things and
not have people just associate them with
doughnuts because they're not just a
doughnut place yep this isn't a war on
carbs I was just in the airport coming
back from Mexico and was right before
Yom Kippur so I ran to Dunkin Donuts and
what did I get from Dunkin Donuts
actually I got two bagels with cream
cheese and I got a bottle of water and I
turned to Claudia and I'm like you know
it's funny Dunkin Donuts sells a lot
more than doughnuts I literally said
that sir last week so I am in favor of
this because people call it Dunkin
already it's not like they're they're
not doing it they sell Donuts they're
not gonna stop selling Donuts if you
bought more Donuts they wouldn't have
had to change their name but clearly
nobody's buying enough to Oh nuts so
they needed to change their name yeah I
think I think it's in an in tune with
what's necessary move as we as we propel
into the future that being said where
did Krispy kream go because Dunkin
Donuts didn't even make the best
doughnuts Krispy Kreme did and now
they're dead well it's just another
reason why New York is you know Satan's
playground because there's no Krispy
Kreme here and there's just one teeny
tiny one but it's in Penn Station there
also no Tim Hortons we have no donut
shops but isn't that a Canadian thing
they have it here but also then you
could also argue that we have like the
artisanal doughnut shops Dominique and
sell dough great I don't I don't want
that oh I don't I don't want gotta go
from Sunday night bar Jonah and I'm
gonna be honest there is such thing as
too much of a good thing it was too many
delicious flavors and I was overwhelmed
but it was very good I like know like it
was good but there was too much going on
like if I'm trying to indulge I just
need a Boston cream doughnut from Krispy
Kreme and like that's all I need you
need your cream filling your soft
doughnut your shoe year of chocolate but
then it's also like I remember back in
the day when it was your birthday in
school and you brought the class
doughnuts yeah you go Duncan was the
easiest it was the easiest but it's also
where you associate doughnuts or maybe
be used to that now is like 20 years ago
which is really sad it's the mini
doughnut
what they did with the mini donut
revolutionized the Munchkin is that an
offensive term is it what munchkin I
don't know I think so it could be it's
not our fault we didn't come up with the
name wow you were so sensitive I mean
the world is sensitive my friend well
I'm gonna call them mini donuts now man
they're not talking at all so they're
the mini little ones yeah those are
birthday parties
those I mean it depends if you had the
kid in class who brought munchkins for
lack of a better term um and then you
had one munchkin like the kid who
brought full doughnuts for everyone and
everyone got their own big donut it's
like that was rich yeah it was amazing
it was nice like you bring like each kid
get six munchkins yeah for lack of a
better term seriously it's weird anyways
I'm here for this Dunkin Donuts also
like anything that you need to do you um
leap ahead of Starbucks go for the goal
of my friends it's not even like I I
have no like way of proving this I think
Starbucks is in trouble
you think but they just opened their
first Starbucks in where was it Italy
Florence or Milan sure it's like where
the espresso was born and now they're
like going in there with their dribble
was a big deal yeah I think that they
just it hasn't come yet but the fact
that they still have plastic straws and
are like behind on this movement which I
love a good plastic straw but we can't
have them anymore no it's not where I
stand I'm saying you're saying I'm
saying you're not letting us have them
anymore not that like you you're saying
we can no I'm not saying that we can I'm
saying that society is telling us right
now that we can't have plastic straws
okay and Starbucks still has them and I
think eventually that's gonna catch up
with them
wait are you for you seriously Claudio
he says you don't watch a show but
Starbucks is one who started the anti
plastic shore movement I literally go
every single day to Starbucks and I have
plastic so usually then your Starbucks
hasn't been affected yet but they're the
ones who started no you know I watch the
show they're the ones who started the
war on straws did they win granny I went
to Starbucks headquarters with his
little clan of yellow-bellied losers
and they got Starbucks today started by
a dream yeah a drinking yeah getting
Starbucks to go back on classic Shores
they now have these like little sippy
cups that are [ __ ] pathetic and then
everyone else yeah let's see you're
kidding it's all started with Starbucks
oh my god
just another reason why they're like
just the worst but also their product
speaks for itself
wait that's crazy I've been walking
around thinking that every single
Starbucks they go into that's Ross you
do anything it's weird that one day
everyone just woke up and felt a certain
way about straws yes Starbucks no it's
Adrian Grenier he does a lot of these
initiatives but he persuaded Starbucks
and then there they are a big player in
the beverage space that now all these
restaurants and everything are banning
straws cities I get did you see that I
didn't know that did you see that mean
of the turtle breaking through the wall
no oh my god it's so funny it's like a
turtle coming through the wall being
like [ __ ] strong you also don't
probably went to us on Instagram
apparently buzz fine yes I do it's fine
oh why should I follow the morning toast
on Instagram when the morning toast
doesn't follow me on Instagram this is
true this is very true
even though I do and I didn't unfollow
even though I noticed that I was not
being followed it's true was I
unfollowed you were everyone was
unfollowed why because now we just have
like a more clear strategy that we're
seeing clearly and the only people that
need to be followed from the morning
toast are obviously the to permanent
hosts Shaddai veteran wah tiffany
thornton so that she can make that ad
money mm-hmm sorry honestly it's a
compliment to you we don't think that
you needed to be followed by us no I
don't I'm just saying it would have been
nice maybe one day okay we'll see we'll
see how today goes and potentially
tomorrow I'm still talking about plastic
straws or is that all do you have
another thing to say yeah no I'm just uh
I think I've said this before and I'll
say it again yes plastic the sea turtles
I'm a very very very big animal activist
I feel terrible for the turtles we need
to talk about our garbageman and our the
people that are disposing of our said
straws in said ocean because how the
[ __ ] do they get there I put my straw in
that garbage
why does that garbage end up in the
ocean can you explain that to me are
they dumping it in the ocean
because then why am I being blamed for
placing my straw in that garbage and the
person that is literally taking my
garbage and emptying it into our
beautiful ocean nobody is talking that
that's true so we are going to the sort
we're not going to the source we're
going to the person selling the straw to
the person that would like to use it
Adri yeah you really should have gone to
the [ __ ] parks department or the the
sanitation committee and said why the
[ __ ] are you dumping all of your garbage
in the ocean for sure I don't know if
it's that simple but I honestly don't
know I'm not saying you fix simple but
how do they get there
landfill overflow they jump your [ __ ]
into the landfill like this just throw
garbage bags into the landfill I believe
so then perhaps it overflows then stars
are blowing in the wind so we end up in
the ocean but here's the real thing
straws make up for less than like 1% of
the garbage in the ocean and there are
other plastic items that are killing our
marine wildlife that are killing more at
a more rapid pace and like I don't know
why we had to start with straws a
utility that is actually very useful it
is useful but I want to know how like
there are so many smart people in this
world they can't make a like a faux
plastic straw that doesn't melt in my
mouth like paper right like like it
doesn't need to be plastic just make one
that's make a better straw to all the
restaurants who are banning straws who
are giving out no straws like you're not
helping anything cuz you can easily give
us a metal straw I yes there means you
have a dishwasher so give me all the
metal sharks you want you banning straws
like just to be cool with Starbucks and
Adrian Grenier like [ __ ] that chick all
you have to do is get some metal straws
also there's literally nothing worse
than putting your mouth on a diner cop
also in your school a city did not give
me a straw your cups better not smell
and you know what more times than not
they do speed you smell yeah a smelly
cup a metal straw is unbelievable I'm
better than a plastic straw so my
especially they they put them in the
freezer they take him out they're nice
and cold they keep your beverage cold as
it as you slurp it
to your lips and everybody now probably
commenting in the comment section bring
your metal straw with you that sounds
like torture that sounds like it's also
a hot metal straw like I need a an
ice-cold metal straw out of my
restaurants freezer but that is better
than a plastic straw much totally so
there's something there maybe a thin
metal a thin metal for what like I'm
saying to replace the plastic straw no
but for me like say right now we're at
work I have a metal straw like I would
have to bring my own straw when I'm like
making my coffee also at Starbucks like
they're not gonna give you a medal start
with every drink cuz even if you throw
those away that could still get the
second turtles and it was like four
restaurants it makes a lot of sense for
Starbucks and other you know quick
beverage places I don't know we need a
new formula I have an idea
we need like it shouldn't be so hard
what about like some no why can't there
just be I'll demonstrate why can't there
just be a straw that's attached to the
lid that just comes up sort of like the
sippy cup but it's just a straw and it
sucks up and but it can't detach but how
do you get the liquid it also extends
down so it's just straw but it's not a
straw the problem is the straw can come
out and it's long mm-hmm it can't get
caught in the turtles mouth it's a whole
piece I guess do you get what I'm saying
there's just like more plastic I don't
know they're not outlawing plastic yet
though I feel and we're on attention
yeah we're on it's all the time it just
confuses really a good solution it's
very good I just feel like there that
there can be and if you want to put me
on a task force like I'd be happy to get
my ideas it's very confusing okay we're
gonna switch gears a little bit because
I know you're big sports guys know and
I'm a big Tim Tebow fan so here we go
Tim Tebow says he listens to softer
music in the gym namely Disney's Moana
soundtrack I feel this on a deeply
personal level Tim Tebow shared his
secret to getting swole in the gym
Disney Music the Heisman winning
quarterback turned beat quarterback
turned baseball minor leaguer appeared
on GMA on Tuesday to promote his new
book this is the day which centers on
motivating people to live their purpose
and shift off of autopilot in their day
to day lives
host Michael Strahan asked Tebow about
his workout music in the TV segment and
suffice is suffice it to say Eminem's 8
mile soundtrack was not at the top of
the playlist quote I think some people
would be shocked I'm a little bit
in the gym because I'm usually pretty
amped up so I listen to softer stuff
Frank Sinatra Disney music Christian
music I think they're even shocked when
I say I even like mallanna I mean it's
not that shocking how far I'll go is
motivating as hell and all just like I
do he should really come to me come with
me to musical Mondays at SoulCycle um
because it really lifts you up you
should come with me next week as you say
Moana soundtrack is not what it's not
mellow and also like Dwayne the rock
Johnson as hard as hell no it's just
like like and Frank Sinatra like it
smell or whatever that's a little melon
it like I think that comparing Moana to
Christian music like Christian music is
mellow actually it's not either pop like
oh my god that's so inspiring when you
got the right Jam Francesca Botticelli
like totally actually I don't even know
what they're talking about I love Tim
Tebow you know that right I do he's cool
why doesn't he play football anymore cuz
he sucks why doesn't he play baseball
anymore probably because he sucks - it's
so crazy that someone who took me I
guess wasn't really that athletically
great really when you go far for himself
he was the the media likes to grab on or
the sports media likes to grab on to
certain people that they thought were
gonna be incredible and then follow
their entire career even through the
garbage Tim Tebow is one of them Johnny
Manziel is another one of them like
Johnny Manziel assuming you know who is
I do I was once in an elevator with him
they are covering every single
interception that he throws in Canadian
football like they have never once
covered the Canadian Football League but
they show every single [ __ ] that he
makes it's the same thing with Tim Tebow
he plays for the like lowest possible
minor league division of baseball and
hits one home run and everybody shits
their pants like it's just the person
that they go with but everybody saying
Oh Tim Tebow like he can really play
baseball like if he could really play
baseball he'd be playing baseball okay
that's there and then him now what going
into like writing a motivational book
like he's clearly grasping at straws to
try and make some semblance of a career
for himself not that I'm not anti Kim
Tebow and it sounds like I'm like really
anti Tim Tebow I'm not
seems like a very nice guy I like when
he talks about college football in ESPN
oh yeah randomly he's a he's a jack of
all trades right as a guest co-host you
should
start talking nicer about him it's okay
I feel like you haven't said anything
that bad no he's just right now he seems
a little bit lost
okay well maybe this book will have him
found it's a it's a motivational book
yes I think it's like definitely find it
in the self-help section got it okay so
what in the world that was my Segway for
sports what is going on in the sports
world football's back yes
you watched at my house yes my pastors
my future and my future Cleveland one
yes
that was crazy and that wasn't supposed
to happen should be actually like what
do you want me to talk about with sports
we want to talk about that game we
talked about that game weirdly because
they were on food first time in three
years coincidentally right after I made
this big you know public statement that
I'm talking to Cleveland um no I
actually feel like I've been up on
what's going on in football because Zack
was in some sort of like not League but
like a fantasy league like what I do
with the Batchelor yeah it's like sudden
death like if you yeah one week survivor
survivor going somewhere survivors or no
it's actually sounds really funny it
sounds like anyone can really play
anyone can play you don't have to have
any knowledge and it's the early stages
of the NFL like the early games always
such a crapshoot
not usually for the Patriots it is but
it's not even it's not that it's a
crapshoot because statistically the
Patriots care less in September like
their record in September is like it's
fairly even and then they end up winning
80% of their games over the season so
they say that the Patriots use September
like it's a learning yeah because they
know that they're gonna probably get to
the Super Bowl anyway but survivor is
you put in usually $200 and you pick a
team every single week and the second
you get a team wrong you're out
and the persons surviving at the end
wins honestly it's usually a huge pot
like a hundred grand like it's no no I
wasn't I was in a pot that was over a
million dollars last year by the way
sad story he gets probably heard about
it in the news seized seized what's that
the pot was seized by the government
what for an illegal gambling ring so the
person that won 1 million dollars didn't
get it you're lying
swear to god wait how is it illegal I'm
not sure like is my
we told bachelor legal eagle I think so
I think you're actually running a
gambling ring but it's online oh it's in
there no by the way this was online too
I don't know how it works maybe there's
like a cap at how much but that's so
crazy it could be a cap on how much I
won my bachelor League a cool hundred
and ten dollars for you to make the pot
bigger I actually lost survivor this
week because I took the Minnesota
Vikings
so did sack yeah because they against
Rams no the bills the Buffalo Bills up
until this week looked like the worst
team in the history of football and all
the best fans yes and then all of a
sudden they came out and just smacked a
really good Vikings team the Vikings
were huge favorites like if you went to
bet the Vikings $100 would have yielded
you like $10 risking a hundred to get 10
versus if you actually bet the bills it
would have been like $100 to win $1,000
they were huge huge underdogs and they
smacked it wasn't even close they were
20 for nothing in the first that is so
crazy
and that's this week in sports so if you
had to predict like someone who are the
best looking teams right now like who
could be Super Bowl contenders who will
we be seeing perform alongside maroon 5
and cardi B the Los Angeles Rams are
real they're incredible I mean yeah but
I mean they went out and they signed
some of the best defensive talent in the
league like they went to the Denver
Broncos and took their like their number
one defender to lead he's injured now
but he's still on their team and the
Rams are putting up some historical
numbers they're averaging over 30 points
a game offensively they're limiting
teams defensively they're three and oh I
think they're gonna end up being
something like 14 and 215 and 1 and I'll
probably win the Super Bowl you can
never count out the Patriots even though
they are actually last in their division
for the first time the Miami Dolphins
are three and OH who are in the Patriots
division and the Patriots are one in two
thanks to Danny Amendola and thanks to
not having Jay Cutler and thanks to
vehicle buh yes being there to support
us Oh Jay Cutler is out Pisa which is
important I'm glad it seems like I'm
very Cavallari that that was the next
logical step yeah see what he does next
do you like his personality cuz people
he's like very dry I think he stinks at
football so like I don't like people
that play football that stinking
football but he played for so long there
was no time when he was good he was
always not very good like he was always
turnover prone did he ever win a Super
Bowl no okay okay so yeah Rams Rams are
great how are the Cowboys they stink
they stink yeah they stink the Giants
got a huge win this week their first win
they also stink ru Giants fan I am I am
I was always a Giants fan then when I
met Claudia she's like oh like we grew
up Jets fans I'm like oh she actually
gives a [ __ ] about football like I'll go
to some Jets games and like that was
just like a part of her lies like her
web of lies like pretending to be a
sports fan and roping me in like oh I
love the Knicks we can go to every game
like I'm literally begging you to sit
second row with me and you won't come I
will go with you anytime and school she
won't like our dad was a Jets fan a
Knicks fan Rangers fan but like we were
like sure so I was a Jets fan for a year
not that I didn't like the Giants but I
just hopped over and when I realized how
bad they were and like I've been a
Knicks fan my whole life which everybody
knows the Knicks are the worst team in
the history of sports they just they
can't win ever and they can't do
anything right so to have another team
that can't win and can't do anything is
like New York sports stinks I mean maybe
it's a reflection on the city and the
traffic I don't know should we talk
about that should we talk about this
week you guys for those any who don't
live in New York well actually you all
know that it's UN General Assembly
General Assembly week because you I'm
sure you're getting as many news
notifications as I am but it makes New
York City shut down because for some
god-awful reason the UN is located in
the heart of New York City all these
politicians ambassadors are here they
travel with their Secret Service and all
these motorcades and you can't get
anywhere like it is the worst week in
the city ever awful like worse than if
the Superbowl we're here you know what I
just thought of that they should do
because the UN is so East for those of
you they don't know
it's literally on the river just what's
on the other side of the UN is it Jersey
City or is it Queen Queen its East true
God what's wrong with me but it's it's
Long Island City they should put a hotel
for all of you an assembly in Long
Island City and have them take a boat
and then you get off you go to the UN
and you go back to Long Island City no
honestly they should really move the UN
it's awful
traffic is awful it makes no sense why
it should be in the busiest city and
also it's like it's an international
body so it could go anywhere in the
world and you choose the place with
already the worst traffic yep and I
can't no it's awful I haven't set like
literally I say home all week even
yesterday I went to pick up my dear
nephew Smee chess and I just knew the
traffic was gonna be so bad I walked all
the way there which took me like 30
minutes but I'm sure would have taken me
longer in anywhere and it of course
needed to rain yesterday for the 9000
day in a row right where do we live I
haven't seen Sun in weeks literally
weeks the only thing that's worse than
Trump or any president coming to New
York because is when the Pope comes no
it doesn't but I'm just like I'm just
saying like that is horrendous this is
terrible Pope coming or the president
coming like it's always just a one day
thing it's really bad so if you know
what's gonna happen
seriously like don't make plans stay
home the UN week is a whole week like I
can't be holed up for a whole week it's
terrible it's terrible and now we're
Claudie and I moved oh yeah you're in
the thick of it we're [ __ ] it took me
so long to get home yesterday you know
what you should do actually since it
like times up with nicely with your
anniversary you shouldn't make your like
every time you guys go on it yeah you
should just schedule it for UN week so
you miss it is UN week always the same
week um always a weekend in September is
that the month is yeah I've never I've
never been so aware of UN week I don't
know why I guess that previously I never
really went from downtown to Uptown so
we never live so close and I never lived
so close
mm-hmm so now I'm feeling the grunt of
it well speaking of your anniversary I
have some positive news
Millennials are causing
u.s. divorce rate to plummet Americans
under the age of 45 have found a novel
way to rebel against their elders
they're staying married no way yes new
data I think said plummeting the
network's divorce rate is plummeting
it's the divorce rate is great news new
data shows younger couples are
approaching relationships very
differently from bad from baby boomers
who married young divorced remarried and
so on Gen X and especially Millennials
are being pickier about who they marry
tying the knot at older ages when
education careers and finances are on
track the result is a u.s. divorce rate
that dropped 18 percent from 2008 to
2060 100 according to an analysis by the
University of Maryland sociology
professor Philip Cowan demographers
already knew the divorce rate was
failing even if the average American
falling even if their mavar American
didn't their question however was why
and what do current trends mean for the
marital prospects of today's newly weds
honestly this isn't surprising
I even like feel a shift amongst Mike
Mike my colleagues I just feel like our
generation really does approach marriage
differently than those of our parents
and probably because a lot of our
parents have gotten divorce and so on
children of divorce like are so affected
by it that they don't want that in the
end they'll not get divorce at all costs
yes it's quite sad I also think that it
probably has something to do with gay
marriage being legalized so more people
are able to get married no perhaps I'm
not saying that they're a massive pool
but but this is from 2000 I guess yeah
no that might make sense but then the
more marriages you could argue then no
this is a good thing I'm not saying it's
I'm just saying that I think there's
like a lot of varying factors and also
like we said of Hollywood is
popularizing the act of getting married
young so I'm here for this and as
someone who's about to get married like
this is such positive news fantastic
news and as we saw in real house eyes
Orange County Monday night the divorce
rate in the OC is about 80 percent um
which is so crazy
never ever moved there apparently this
oh well the divorce rate not just on the
show know in Orange County is they oh
the divorce rate on the show is I think
about a hundred percent right now um but
I'm glad to see like so that actually
had me feeling like really no but that
makes sense
mystic about marriage because everyone
says the divorce rates
percent you know every one out of two
couples technically so like either
you're getting more song written forces
like statistics would show but this is
just some positive news and I and I'm
really here for it mmm-hmm I mean it
doesn't mean I mean it makes perfect
sense to me that a place like Orange
County would have a high divorce rate
same thing that Beverly Hills like I
feel like there's so much there there
are a lot of fake mentions know it's
also a lot of fake marriages in in that
in those areas I'm sure that the New
York divorce rate is higher like on
Fifth Avenue in Park Avenue than it is
in on the Lower East Side you know what
I mean
I got feel like I feel like when wealth
comes fake marriages come as well
unfortunately that's an interesting I
also feel like back in the day like I'm
watching um Mad Men now or I was
watching Mad Men so like you know
post-world war ii era like divorce was
really frowned upon and not a lot of
people got divorced and then the
children of those marriages were like i
wish my parents got divorced and then
that's the baby boomers who then
divorcing his old socially normal that
they were like oh i can get divorced i
want to and then now we're seeing it
like it just constantly that's a very
good point but i'm glad to be on this
end of it
me too a great time to be alive great
time to be married
it is great time to be married how's it
going it's great how was your trip my
trip was wonderful for those of you that
don't know i'm sure that she actually
spoke about it already i just don't know
but we switched our trip from puerto
rico to Cancun in 12 hours I surprised
Claudia with a trip to Puerto Rico for
our anniversary and a big [ __ ] rock on
her finger you know I'm not sure that
she showed I think she didn't and she
showed out her story and you should all
follow me girls my job Jackie no
problems pup with no job well there's no
job Olivia show you are a body by snitch
hungover and hungry tiffany thornton and
most importantly big soft big sauce my
personal account in case you just want
to see more pictures of just me in case
you want to see a hair at Nobu yes which
people can't still can't get over
norther they share i haven't been back
since no it's in i'll never go back
even though i think it was my own hair
no it's true
i guess they don't watch what was i
saying your trip big yes so i surprised
sir to Puerto Rico then all of a sudden
this disastrous hurricane came and who
knew but Puerto Rico is just below not
just below the Carolinas but it's below
the Carolinas and what came from that
hurricane came a tropical storm called
Isaac and I was getting weather warning
saying alert don't go to Puerto Rico and
I was so excited to go to Puerto Rico
because I want to help stimulate their
economy I love Puerto Rico
it's an unbelievable place you guys have
had many great memories it's in America
you have beautiful casinos you have
beautiful weather oh my god Porter he
goes amazing you look to your right and
you have McDonald's but you're staying
in the Ritz and you're having a great
time and it's a it's a beautiful
beautiful place so when I found out
about the weather warning I wasn't gonna
let it stop us Claude he's like what
can't so I'm like when the [ __ ] are we
gonna go on vacation again so what I did
Cancun I pivoted you switched our
flights went west like I did Clark the
only thing that I will say about Cancun
which I've heard mixed things I guess it
depends on when you go the water not
swimmable claudia said the same thing
you guys said the water was just brown
no we love the ocean
we loved swimming in the ocean diving
the waves yeah you know big ocean people
and the sand was rocky the water was
brown you needed to swim out like a
hundred meters to get to non brown water
got it that's not you know I'm sorry
about that and I and we went jet skiing
and what felt like the Hudson River
it was the lagoon that's like this a
lagoon is dirty dig you jet ski yeah do
you get up jet ski Jackie check oh I'm
sorry
water brain washing oh my god what
impossible is so hard I hadn't done it
in ten years like and then I went I know
summer human Claudia you guys all say
the same thing you were you were
champion water-skier waterskiing in
Spain yeah you were good in the ocean
that was great I'm not saying it what
uses muscles that I didn't even like I
never felt that way in my whole life
like it was so hard and I wonder if it's
just cuz like I'm old or weak
I don't know mm-hmm it's probably both
no it's
it's it's so hard I wasn't even close to
getting up I think it has to do with
your abdominal muscles of which I have
none yeah and something about your lower
back I'm telling you okay we have a
fifth and final story because
technically the first story was to part
of his legal news and I wouldn't have
brought it up but I want your opinion on
it yes instagram's founders are leading
the company the founders of Instagram
has resigned from the business they
started eight years ago in San Francisco
and built into a global phenomenon used
by a billion people
Kevin's dis shaman Mike Krieger founded
the photo sharing app in a co-working
space in 2010 it became a runaway
success attracting tens of millions of
users before the cofounders sold it to
Facebook in 2012 for 1 billion dollars
with the tech heavyweights backing
Instagram continued its spectacular
growth adding features including videos
stories and most recently its own
version of TV epic sale by the way awful
that's the only thing that they know
that is yeah it's because they didn't
copy anyone we'll get to that but sis
John the company CEO and Krieger its CTO
have now decided to leave their posts
that will deprive Facebook of the two
key leaders of an app that's growing
much faster than Facebook itself very
true very sad a quote we're planning on
taking some time off to explore our
curiosity and creativity again sistrum
said in a blog post late Monday who a
building new things requires that we
step back understand what inspires us
and match that with what the world needs
that's what we plan to do he added that
they both being excited for the future
of instrument Facebook in the coming
years as we transition from leaders to
to users in a billion that's a sad way
of talking about it yes like when I saw
the news I was like honestly surprised
that they still worked there and didn't
just like cash out um but this is really
shift people to the core and the more
that I read about it the more I
understand why because it seems to sell
up at this point even wit or I'm just
joking it's ok you could stop if you
could stop joking that'd be great it's
hard I have I'm choking on something I'm
okay I know I just might die we're fine
it's I just don't okay just wait till
after the show okay it seems as though
since the merger that Instagram kind of
operated independently if they
independently a Facebook at least as
much as it could but now with these two
leaving it seems as though Instagram is
really gonna be like more a part of
Facebook which is not a good
thing because Facebook is a dinosaur and
Mark Zuckerberg is a thief creators
create that is why they left I'm shocked
that they didn't leave our lair
they made a map that was I mean we loved
it and I don't think that it will change
the way that the app is at all like
people are worried like oh it's gonna go
all ads like all Facebook like it
already is all ads and you still love it
it's not going any more addi than it is
right now I think that maybe I don't
know they'll start a new app that's good
too I don't think so I feel like yes
certain bother me creators create but I
think that these two guys like
definitely got like really lucky I don't
know that they'll strike this sort of
gold again and then you know anyway they
create will pale in comparison so if I
were them I would just take the money
and run and just go live a luxurious
life
however Facebook once upon a time like
was like water like you couldn't go a
day without it like you couldn't breathe
like you couldn't exist as a human being
without it and that has really changed
like because of whatever functionalities
they made they ran Facebook into the
ground Facebook grand Facebook into the
ground yes and now I only am on it for
the premium warning toasters Facebook
groups and subgroups which are
incredible and but Facebook has nothing
to do with that No
so I do I think that now that Instagram
really is in the hands of Mark
Zuckerberg it will be destroyed in a
very slow it won't be destroyed in
assuming way but I feel like like how
did they destroy Facebook they destroyed
Facebook in a hundred different ways
number one they took away you being able
to see your friends organic reach on
Facebook went to complete [ __ ] that's
true so when I log on to Facebook I
don't even know what I see I can't tell
you what I see when I scroll through if
I ever saw what I would see if I wasn't
in Toaster group the second thing is
that they made it was probably not a
mistake for them because it was a great
way for them to monetize but making a
mess and messenger app so that I can't
even talk within the Facebook app was a
huge problem so now you just have if you
want to talk to your friends you have to
go to a different app they they [ __ ]
up the user flow that means say they
wanted to own all these
and like they want facebook messenger to
be the new iMessage which isn't gonna
which isn't gonna happen like really
saying your lane and like no no what's
up cuz now people are sparse and parsed
among multiple Facebook apps and so you
know what I'll just use none of them
thank you not to get to tactical into
like media and marketing but just for a
second I think that face okay you're
here for your level of expertise yes
Facebook is the paid media vertical and
Instagram is the organic medium vertical
so I don't ever think and I'll explain
what that means but I don't ever think
that Instagram will go down that path
simply because they're owned by the same
people and they don't want them to do
the same thing they want them to each
have their own ways of making money in
my opinion I think that this change
signals the fact that Instagram is gonna
become more like Facebook I I don't
think so I I really hope not
thoroughly enjoy Instagram and Instagram
is just more personal because you think
about it like back in the day like every
night I went out I used to post an album
to Facebook like everyone did it was
just you know but but that's not because
like tree you can have a name you would
have an inside-joke from the night and
it was it was your album title now you
post one picture to Instagram from the
night
your inside joke from the night is your
caption and just the whole way that we
approach photos and sharing and like our
personal lives has been completely
transformed by Instagram and now it was
a better because it's better I think
that Facebook actually in the beginning
it wasn't better people like really
we're starting to we're trying to use
Instagram like that you Facebook posting
multiple pictures from an evening and
then like you would get no engagement
and you had to shift you had to change
your behavior which actually I think was
hard for some people I know some of my
friend said I had to unfollow because of
it and even for me it was like it took
me a while to like figure out how to use
Instagram now I have presets and I'm
like the most premium blogger on that's
why they put in slides right slides have
definitely helped that definitely made
it more like Facebook sure and I think
also Facebook really started to
prioritize news that was like a big push
for them getting a [ __ ] spam call
like scram they started to prioritize
news and then like people would just
seem using their feeds and like most
people didn't want to see that like you
want to see your friends I spent all
this time like making friendships on
Facebook like why do I want to see this
a random article of a website I don't
even follow how did this come here how
did this get here
why now why this article PETA
advertising because they have too much
data on you
that they can use right well they're not
even using it well because if it was an
article that I wanted to click like I
wouldn't mind that you served it to me
using my data and they don't have the
same level of data on Instagram the only
level of data they have is by comparing
your email address from Instagram to
Facebook to know that they're the same
person you're always going to be
targeted with that garbage on Facebook
that's not just my personal opinion the
user flow of Facebook and Instagram are
so different I think because we started
Facebook on desktop the fact that I will
go like I won't of course I use the app
but like if I'm on my computer Facebook
is where I go like it's a fun thing for
me to use on the computer would you
agree it's hard for me to say because
yes I spend a lot of time on Facebook
but just because of our community there
and I don't so I'm not like oh the fun
you use it on the but you use it on the
computer yes more than you would on
mobile I don't like looking at things on
my phone in general like I can't watch
videos right like I use my iPad which it
has it sure I'm not the right person to
be asking these questions I have weird
behavioral patterns what I'm trying to
say is that I think that the way that
Facebook works is that if you are using
it on your computer and or you're just
not using the app or mobile version
there or just like when you go on a
website and you have those annoying
banner ads and enroll videos like that's
something that you can have because it's
a dot-com Instagram like sure maybe six
people in the world go to Instagram calm
and their computer but everybody uses
the app and the ads are just different
there in feed they distract you Lassiter
they're much better because it's it
flows great it's not disrupt really it's
not destructive and they really curate
it I'm saying that I think that's gonna
change and now I'm gonna start seeing
ads for sure that I see would see on
Facebook and it's like how the [ __ ] did
I got here but why would it change if
they've if they've cracked the code
where they can make better ads yeah
continue to make better now they can
make more money they can make the same
money it's not more money no it would be
more money if they're serving more ads
and like just selling more user data
like because I see ads right now but
it's not super annoying but if they feel
like they're driving Facebook into the
ground they're not also gonna drive
Instagram into the ground but they don't
know that they're driving Facebook into
the ground like they think that maybe
they're not the greatest thing since
sliced bread
sure I don't think I don't think
instagrams in trouble I don't
because they make we make five words now
they make too many efforts to be better
than everybody else with the exception
of IG TV which I said as like a joke
before but it's so true the reason why I
flopped is because it was their own idea
right I well technically I think they
were trying to steal from like make
people use it like YouTube um I [ __ ]
hate IG TV like and I do videos up there
and it's like I want to delete them
because I don't even want I have the
weirdest video what do you have I don't
know like some interim story that I
really liked like the day that I found
out IG TV was a thing and then every is
like ooh it's it's the next YouTube like
you're gonna get paid on a CPM like you
got to build it up I'm like alright
nobody literally nobody uses it nobody
and it's like if it's the next YouTube
then you should want people to be
posting the same content that they would
be posting few but now just posted to
Instagram like snapchat it's like I
could post it to snapchat or Instagram
story so I'm gonna post it to Instagram
stories where I'm gonna get more
eyeballs but I have to now make custom
content for IG TV it's not my YouTube
videos no it's vertical which I like
vertical videos but now you're giving me
another job I have a lot of jobs I'm
good
oh and nobody's watching it's weird
maybe they'll make a different app also
I've never been big on videos on
Instagram and I know that they perform
really well for people because Instagram
wants them to but I don't enjoy watching
videos Instagram like I am there for the
flow I try and put my stories like so
that you can watch them without sound
and it's like if you need sound it says
sound on just like this morning watch my
story with sound because it's [ __ ]
hilarious um but I enjoy INSERM as like
a visual platform only and they they're
[ __ ] with it I love video I know you
do you're making watch videos before I
hate when people make me watch videos on
their phones that makes me do it all the
time and I'm like no totally I love
Instagram videos I love sound on
I prefer stories with sound just think
it's a it's just like a better
experience do I love photos definitely I
think instagrams struck a great balance
with photo and video and I can enjoy
both the only thing that they fail that
is IG TV I think the rest of the
platform as I'm sure you can agree is
fantastic in terms stories is [ __ ]
incredible it is like the whole entire
journey it's also incredible in snapchat
did it - it wasn't though because what
they've done with with
my pups I think it's is huge well back
totally the fact that people can go on
to the boy with no job
Instagram story I mean you're already
here so you don't have to do this but if
you could have swiped up to watch
today's episode gone watch for a little
bit and then when you're done swiped
right back down and you're exactly where
you were like that's genius ninja game
tagging people and stories change the
game they must work on their filter it's
like how come snapchat made us beauty
queens and like Instagram makes us like
I don't I don't even know they like and
we've been saying it for so long like
I'm sure that snapchat patent did those
filters I'm sure you just can't they
patented their filters and they didn't
patent the exact technology that made
them what they are I have no idea how
are they not able to sue Instagram it's
the craziest thing it was like peloton
suing flywheel for some like at-home DVD
videos and since I'm Chuck handsome
Instagram I don't get it
they probably can and they probably
should they probably should just like
too busy like being married to Miranda
Kerr it's like he got everything he
wanted I feel like he gave up oh he won
he gave up on us and we gave up on him
and I feel like that's there actually he
gave up on us know Kylie Jenner gave up
on him and then he gave up on us know
the Kardashians are the only people who
still use snapchat now but Kylie
Jenner's tweet oh yeah she doesn't use
snapchat single-handedly destroyed
snapchat it was it was going through a
rough patch I'm not gonna lie because
everybody the second better when we were
like where do we go it wasn't even that
it was like everybody all of a sudden
was so invested in Wall Street they're
like ooh snapchat IPO it's like dipping
snapchats half of its value the app must
suck like the reason why was half of its
values because it couldn't sell anything
not because we didn't like the user
experience we still enjoyed snapchat but
then everybody's like oh clearly this
app is going to the ground Kylie
Jenner's like yeah I don't use snapchat
anymore but now I do believe it's time
chat peace the Kardashians to say on the
platform because they all are on it
smart when they don't yeah I mean smart
but that being said or they can exact
same stuff on Instagram stories I'm sure
yes I don't watch any sounds with
anymore so I don't really know either do
I also how do you feel about the
Instagram algorithm cuz everyone loves
to complain about it but like I barely
noticed
sometimes it's confusing when I see
something from literally three days ago
but that just means that Instagram is
running out of [ __ ] to show me and I
need to get off Instagram you know where
you need to follow more people I thought
like 500 plus oh that's the time how
many do you follow like a hundred oh wow
how do you feel about the algorithm do
you think that it's like helped you
hurted you do you not notice yeah I
think people who post premium content
don't notice the algorithm no firm a
from a creator standpoint like not
personal Instagram same went from big
soft I hate it I absolutely hate the
algorithm because I want to see my
friends but from a boy with no job
perspective I can post a hundred times
today and you'll never see them twice in
a row that's so I love the algorithm for
engagement from a brand or personality
perspective but from a personal
perspective it stinks but if you really
like your friends enough just turn on
post notifications yeah and then you can
see them not even that you get served
the pictures of the people that you
engage with the most so if you really
want to see your friends like their
pictures and you'll see that that's true
to watch your stories and your stories
will get up first but if you're ignoring
your friends then they're gonna think
you're doing it on purpose so it really
is not you that's true that's true
I see the post of the people that I
engage with the most they can ask me to
and so just like your friendship true
don't turn on post notifications for
anyone how annoying could that be I
would never have someone to turn on my
post notifications it's like that's the
quickest way to get sick of me it's
funny now that I'm thinking about post
notifications remember when you were on
Facebook you would accidentally star
someone yes so I still hate a move yeah
anytime they made a move and like I
would be like who the [ __ ] is this
person that starred it's literally some
random person from my high school that I
never clicked star but like who this
person uploaded a photo and I never like
realized until like they told me that I
starred them like that's why they're
only serving me this kid's profile
pictures like that was weird
that was weird Dana still gets a
notification for everything that I do
and I think she prefers it that way I
was just about to say I feel like that's
intentional ya know I think it started
as an accident I'm also listening at
hers she's listed as my nephew on
Facebook talking about that with
somebody else it's really so appropriate
because I'm the number one and Sameach s
in this group I was just talking about
that with someone they're like I go on
my Facebook and I have a bunch
like fathers and sons and brothers and
like it's just like that was like like
six months in like tenth grade right
that was really cool yeah it was just
like Oh like we need to be connected on
Facebook in some way but your brother
father are never actually your brother
and father was just friends I'm still
engaged to Margo looming on Facebook
even though I am engaged
exactly yeah we got engaged on Facebook
like now 2006 what's that 12 years ago
yeah it's been a really great
relationship so far we never got hitched
but I like the engagement they say it's
the grass the greatest time in your life
and if you're not happy wedding
engagement um they've never been engaged
you know engagement is the greatest time
in your life if you're not planning your
wedding no no I mean III think that if
you ask unless these people are
absolutely insane I think you asked Nana
to send people what's the most stressful
part of your marriage it would 100% be
the engagement that's so crazy I never
knew that I always thought the
engagement was the best time because
it's like you have all this shine and
attention on you and like you're engaged
you're not like an old married couple
yet it's all so fresh and exciting it
knew the first week of being engaged is
the best time of your life for some
people and then it's the worst yes for
something but then it's the worst and
for actually what I hear from everybody
is that year two of marriage and on is
the best time of your life that is so
great that's what I've been hearing I've
been hearing that the engagement like
typically is very very stressful
planning the wedding is very very
stressful and that unfortunately spills
over a bit into year one just like the
stresses of having a life with somebody
like you just learn like it didn't
really happen with us because we were
living together before but in case you
just moved in together or now you're
taking a deeper look at each other's
finances like everybody just becomes a
little bit more nosy yeah and then after
year one it's just like okay all of our
cards are out on the table and now we
can just live totally that's what I've
heard that makes a lot of sense well I
look forward to marriage for a lot of
reasons including getting health
insurance so I can finally go to the
dentist because my my teeth hurt they're
good though they look good they were
surprised quite sure they're about I
have really bad teeth by the way it's
probably because you use Crest
Whitestrips no it's not a sense
my dentist said like if Crosswhite chips
don't hurt you they're actually great
and if they help you whiten your teeth
then that's great you don't have to
spend money on they don't hurt you no
not really if I use them too often they
would but I don't use them anything I
don't use them often enough but it's
like just my back teeth are all [ __ ]
mm-hmm see that I got them out because I
thought it would help and it definitely
helped but I know I have like one tooth
that's like decaying um and I was just
trying to wait till I got married to fix
it but I think I may just have to bite
the bullet didn't go mm-hmm you can't
get insurance if you're not married like
with Zach no I have to I'll get on his
insurance when I'm married until you can
just get on it right now
I don't think so maybe you can but it
seems like a lot of paperwork and phone
calls and talking to Authority not a lot
of paperwork
what are you hopped onto my insurance
real quick okay I'll look into it you
know I go to your dentist too cuz you
yeah I was looking for a dentist and now
I go to yours and it's very fancy yeah
which I like and central and I sort I'm
not on you one week I would just have to
say don't go there don't go there now
it's terrible and I have insurance by
the way insurance doesn't cover dental
we're getting a little off track here
but unless you have dental insurance
yeah I used to really rich must be nice
um anyways thank you for joining me is
there anything that you want to get off
your chest like I know we didn't talk
about you a lot this time and if you
join me tomorrow maybe we could delve
into that and I'll get questions from
people um
but how how are things with you first
can we in the microphone hear my stomach
rumbling because it just made some of
the craziest [ __ ] noises are you
hungry
ever I have no idea maybe I was wild
like I was thinking that they were about
to hear like oh you know what I'll go
back later and listen where it's 11:30
700 it's over an hour isn't it crazy how
time flies
wise anything that I would like to talk
about it's a great question house vo yes
rain is very very tough on a pup I
cleaned him I spent all day yesterday
washing him and drying him and then
taking him out again washing him and
drying him it was a it was a hard day
for Fernan serious but I was happy to do
it
but yes the OU is great announcements
here we formally I've been talking about
this for months my podcast is here there
are no recorded episode so you can't go
and listen but I'm just letting you guys
know that it is here so if you want to
go and follow it's a private account
with nothing posted creating
anticipation
what's a call it's called the Schmidt's
CH e sh I know s hvit Z the schvitz
what is a sports culture comedy podcast
that is so funny who's who's on it me my
friend Jack and my friend Victor are you
ever gonna have any like special guest
hosts
hundred-percent this is this is the
beginning of a new era that's really
excited I'm very very excited it's
called the schvitz and for everybody
that doesn't know what fitting is it's
sweating in Yiddish and when you go to a
steam room they call it the schvitz or a
Fitz and when you watch sports it should
see there should it seeing your face
they're switching your scripts and
you're eating buffalo wings you're
sitting there your team's down and the
fourth your shits a great all about
sweating it's a great name did you come
up with it I did that's really I'm
really excited about it I'm excited for
you what a great note to end on there's
a very good chance that you will be back
here with me tomorrow yes which you know
what I wouldn't hate it makes my job a
lot easier thank you all for tuning in
today please follow the morning toast on
Facebook Instagram YouTube make sure to
leave us a podcast review if you're
listening to the podcast including you
Lauren Elizabeth I am wearing your top
today on the show xle bye Lauren
Elizabeth this is the Claudia top
because I miss her so much she has the
cute she came on the show last week she
just lost her launched her clothing line
and she sent me some goodies it's not
I'm so cute or he looks likes it like
looks like it was my own yeah I like it
anyways thank you all for tuning in
please follow me out check your problems
you know this is all I have where can
people follow you they can follow me at
boy with no job which I'm sure that they
already know and if you don't you're
missing out on a premium experience and
you can follow me at big soft which you
probably won't because otherwise I would
have more followers than I do you you do
pretty well for yourself it's fine 22k
like look
me this is 100k face I don't have one
pimple
that's unbelievable skin mono should be
like a beauty blogger I should skin like
people love that's nice too makeup
tutorials and stuff or like just like
your skin care routine yeah and then and
then mm to makeup I'm not sure that
that's me well we'll see about it um
also I had one more thing to say
oh yes doing morning twisters membership
all day if you are waiting to get in and
you requested a while ago definitely be
requests because they can get bumped to
the top the questions are premium if
your answers aren't you don't get it I'm
sorry mm-hmm have an amazing day
everyone thank you all for tuning in
you